all right let's go to uh sarah in
bismarck north dakota what's up sarah
how are you hey i think i just
mispronounced that
is it bismarck yes it is
yes i can read thank you all right that
made me feel better about my life
all right so hey what's going on how are
you i'm good how are you
good good good good so how's how's it
going what can i do to help
um well i have a question about my
teenager i have a son who is 17.
he has an adhd diagnosis but
we don't have him on medication because
we tried a few different ones and had
really bad side effects from those
okay but anyway he's really struggling
in school right now he's
um failing i think two classes
and these and a couple other ones and
then a c but
um we just have really really struggled
with him and
school and he just has no motivation
to want to do good in school to do well
and like we've tried a lot of different
things we've
and it used to work and we only
threatened to take away his electronics
or we would take away his electronics
take away his cell phone and
he'd work you know do what he had to to
get his grades back up so he could get
his
stuff back and and now that doesn't even
work anymore and it just he just
doesn't want to seem to understand why
he needs to
do good in school
and you know other things too i mean he
like he has no desire to
get his driver's license each doesn't
seem to need it he says and
i just i don't know how to get him
motivated i guess
so take me back to
your um take me back to
are you still married yep take me back
to you and your husband
um y'all's dating in your marriage what
was that like
well actually i i am divorced from
mason's dad okay um
i remarried when mason was five
okay and we're still married we have
three other children so is those mason
the oldest
mason's the oldest yep awesome so tell
me about
your tell me about the dating life
what was it like being a single mom
dating
with a young kid
well you know um it was great
i actually met my husband on match.com
and he was like the first person that i
really dated after mason's dad and it
was
even when we were emailing back and
forth like i just had a feeling that
that he was the one and here we are 12
years later
very cool so why did you and mason's dad
get divorced um well
mason's dad and i we were high school
sweethearts um
and so i guess i just kind of felt like
the expectation that we would get
married and i guess that's what i
thought that i wanted and
looked past a lot of other things
thinking that eventually he was going to
grow up
and get past the wanting to go out all
the time and be the center of attention
all the time and ultimately he didn't
um he he is a people person and wants to
be out going doing seeing whatever and i
wanted to be a wife and a mom
and those two worlds didn't really go
very well together
he ended up having an affair
we tried to kind of do some counseling
and stuff afterwards and
but everything was his way or the
highway so i kind of just
said okay that's fine gotcha so
well thank you for for being vulnerable
and welcome me back there so how old was
mason when all that went on he
he was two okay and so
um as we work through this by the way
and this is for you and for every
listener
i've wrestled over the past five six
seven eight nine
years as we talk through these things
because it's hard to
be honest and it's hard to paint a full
picture that
offers hope and light without
people's natural tendency to want to
focus on
blame and shame does that make sense
yep so i want to paint a full picture
as i can in in you know just a few
minutes here
but i want to do that with your promise
that you
your your goal your emphasis your
you'll end this call with a smile on
your face looking forward
not trying to re-edit the story of the
past
which is something you can't re-edit is
that cool oh
yeah absolutely awesome okay so
when did mason start checking out you
said you used to be able to
threaten him with things like i'm gonna
take this away or i'm gonna
you have to do this or else when did he
finally just say you know what i don't
care
um probably about a year
or so ago okay
talk to me about that um
well you know yeah i think
like his his sophomore year we were
still able to
kind of um say hey you're gonna
lose this or you need to do that but i
think you know once he
school stopped last year with kobed and
then
he was home and he actually even started
out the school year
our kids here did go back to school last
fall on a hybrid schedule so like every
other day
but they also had the option to do 100
home school
and so it gave mason the option to
choose which one
um and he chose to do homeschool
uh or 100 distance education or whatever
and so um
i would you know i would say that during
that time
frame is kind of it's gone downhill for
sure
yeah so
what is something that mason loves that
he zones in on
and he will just lose time
um electronics um
talk to me reading on his phone
okay talk to me about it what's he
reading
where does he go what kind of vortex
does he get into like talk me through
that
um well he pretty much stays in his room
unless it's meal time and it's getting
harder to get him to come out for that
um and he just he'll sit on his phone
and he just reads
he lays in bed um last night i think he
fell asleep when he got home from school
and i went down to his room at nine
o'clock and
he was i woke him up i'm like mason
you're not going to sleep tonight
so and he i guess i think anime is kind
of
what he's been reading okay
so um i'm gonna say some things that are
not very popular and
i want you to go with me for a minute is
that cool
sure all right so the most convincing
evidence i have read about
the development of adhd
i reject wholeheartedly that it's a
brain disorder
i reject wholeheartedly that a kid's
brain is broken
if they have adhd mainly because i
am a card-carrying member of that crew
it's not a dysfunction as as it is as
much a response
and if we're in another show i've
actually been on other people's
shows if you will to discuss and argue
and debate
whether it's a genetic thing or this or
that
the most compelling research i have read
suggests
it is a natural response to maternal
stress
a chaotic early childhood
and a chaotic and or
power driven elementary school middle
school high school years
and so it not only doesn't surprise me
it paints me a picture that's both
sad and encouraging okay so hear me say
that
that when he was his youngest that it
the time that
a young child would need the most in i'm
going to keep going back to this one
word connection connection connection
the most connection you were dealing
with a
major trauma a person that you had loved
and hitched your wagon to
for years suddenly violated a core
covenant of yours
right yep and then you had this
thing called trust that you trusted
yourself
and that guy took that away from you and
the resulting
tears and heartbreak and let's work on
this
in fights in his way highways all those
things
for a little two-year-old or
three-year-old or five-year-old
and then you introduce some other guy to
the picture who sounds like he's
wonderful and great i'll go with that
awesome all of that is
is chaos for a little kid right not
right wrong or indiff well some of it's
not right but
it's chaos okay and so the brain becomes
scattered
to to use dr gabor mate's word it
becomes it picks up highly
um it picks up different things in the
environment
it locks in on some things and it
completely ignores others
all in this loop-de-loop-de-loop it
becomes highly highly sensitive to
rejection
highly highly sensitive to am i valued
here
and here's where it's hard most parents
know
one technique and that is power that is
i am bigger than you i am
stronger than you i own your stuff so
you will do what i
want you'll do what i say or i will take
stuff away from you
i will withhold things from you whether
it's you can't play in little league or
you can't ride this bike or you can't
have your video games or whatever
i'm gonna take that away and that
actually works for a season
just because you're bigger i got bigger
muscles than you do right
and then you run into a wall where
there's always a tipping point
often it's when kids go to college for
the first time and they feel
quote unquote free and that freedom
translates to a kid who's struggling
adhd is you don't have to do anything
which then turns into i don't move i
just eat
i just play video games all day and then
the biochemistry
kicks in when your body's got to move
and you got to eat healthy and you got
to get out and stop staring at screens
and so on and so forth right
so there's this power dynamic
where you're going to do what i say or
we're going to do x y and z there's
going to be a consequence
and we'll loop back to this because
those are important too
you do what i say it was going to be
consequences and it works and it works
and it works and then a pandemic hits
and then a kid gets a weird thing that
they've never had before which is called
control
i get to choose whether i go to school
or not i get to choose whether i'm
around other people or not
and since school for adhd kids is often
a failure factory it's often a reminder
about how you don't fit in
of course i'm going to opt for home
which for an adhd kid whose brain is
screaming for connection
is you know it's a it's a death gong
from an old
you know from an old kung fu movie that
you just
rings the gong and all of a sudden you
know oh it's coming right
and then over time the same power
techniques they don't work anymore
and kids begin to just unhook i'm out
right and now you're faced with a 17
year old and i need you to know there
are millions in your situation
you're faced with a 17 year old who's
just
unplugged from life and he's going to go
down his own rabbit holes because that's
where he can escape
and so the the challenge you have
in a short order is he a senior or a
junior
a junior a junior okay so
you have a year and a half or you've got
a little more than a year
and it you'll have your work cut out for
you okay and it's gonna depend on how
much
how far down the rabbit hole you want to
go and it's going to depend on
you being able to transition from a
short-term game to a long-term game
okay the goal here is to
over connect with him to let him know he
has not only value but he's got a role
in this house
and that role the house the house
ecosystem functions only because he's in
it
and that when he opts out when he
chooses to
not do his academic work when he chooses
to not help around the house
then the system falls down without him
not
there is an operating system that we are
making you be a part of
and if you don't we're going to take
things that you love away from you okay
and so what does that actually look like
okay so let me just pause right here is
any of this ringing true
or do you think i sound like a hippie
actually it sounds very interesting okay
and here's the thing that stinks parents
were
20 years ago 15 years ago parents were
told how your kids got adhd they've got
a brain disorder here's some medicine
and it's going to fix them
and the crappy part about most
medications for adhd is their speed
and they work for everybody for a short
term right
we all know what it's like to wake up i
mean to not sleep and then we just
mainline coffee it'll prop you up till
about noon right
and then you've got a hard decision to
make am i not going to sleep tonight or
am i going to
just crash in the afternoon that's
that's the trajectory of a kid
right and so good for you guys for
recognizing the side effects
but then you're left with what do we do
now okay so
here's what i want you to start thinking
through right
do you want your son to grow and learn
or do you want him to do right
and what i want to convince you of or
hope you will get is i can't convince
you of it
is growing and learning is gonna end up
in him
living the right way okay and he's gonna
a rough
road to hoe i do i still do the other
night
as i was laying down to go to bed my
wife said and i quote and we've been
together 20 something years
i got a job i go to every day i got
health insurance okay so i want you to
know the future's bright for your son
but she said as i'm getting into bed hey
are you doing okay
and i said yeah why do you think that
and she said well just look around in
our room
and whenever the room starts to look
like this i know you're not doing okay
to which then i got all huffy and puffy
and i got out of bed
i was so tired and i cleaned the room i
was like i'll just take five minutes and
do this
it took like 45 minutes because it was
such a train wreck
and so i need you to know that it's
still something i'm working on to this
day
okay and it's become i've
found people to connect with not that
try to beat me into submission
okay so here's a couple of things you
can do
number one i would take your son out
just to you
get him off site get him out of your
house and take him somewhere
like the joke on this show is always
take somebody to breakfast i like
breakfast because people are
awake and they're not exhausted and
they're not trying to text with their
friends at 10 o'clock at night
and just get a pulse on him see how he's
like doing how does he feel what's going
on
and let him know hey i've tried to do
this one thing this way for so long
i'm sorry it's not working and i'm much
more interested in loving you
than having your electronics at the top
of my closet
so i'm gonna pause right there is the
idea of going and being vulnerable with
your son
is that hard is that something you've
already tried is that something you're
willing to do
um well you know we've um we've tried
throughout the years to do
one-on-ones with all four of the kids
and
uh we're kind of we're not consistent
with it at all
um but i mean it's definitely something
that we
have on our radar and would like to do
more of for sure
okay does he have a good relationship
with his stepdad
um it's kind of kind of hit and miss
okay does he still is he still connected
to his
birthday um yeah he
but his his birth dad lives
um in las vegas okay so okay he doesn't
see him
all that often so here's what i want you
to do
i want you just you i want you to write
out
on a piece of paper take some time i
want you to take a couple hours to do
this
now when you remember the things about
your son that you love
funny memories y'all have together from
the past
things that you love about him quirks
silly things when he makes you double
over with laughter
when you thought he was going to tank
something and he came through in the
clutch whatever that may be
he's a great artist he is silly he's and
these can range the all 17 years of his
life
i want you to write those down and i
want you to take him out to breakfast
and say i'm your mom you have to listen
to me tell you this stuff
okay and he'll roll his eyes and be like
mommy and you gotta make him turn his
phone off put his phone in your purse
mum i don't want to be no i'm gonna say
some things to you
and it's gonna start with i love you
and i've been trying to show you i love
you by trying to make you get good
grades
and i'm sorry i really really want you
to get good grades because i know you're
super smart and i want you to be
accomplished i want you to achieve great
things
but i've gone about it by taking stuff
away from you
first instead of connecting with you
first
and then i want you to ask him how he's
doing how are things going how are you
feeling
and then ultimately here's the ultimate
goal here okay
number one you've got to get him to buy
into your home system
how your home works that he's a vital
member of that place that it can't
work without him and that when he
chooses
to not be a part of it his his decision
impacts other people
right it's purpose it's value it's
connection
okay and so at some point after he knows
you're connected and he knows
hey you know what you're 17 if you're
gonna fail you're gonna be in summer
school all summer
and you're gonna have to repeat your
senior year
you get to choose to do that you're 17.
right not under my roof i can just hear
the listeners right now
not under my roof i'm taking away all
the electronics and what i want to point
you to is how's that working out
it's not it's not he's going down a
deeper and deeper and deeper hole
could you constrict him so much
absolutely
you could cut off all power all internet
you could take us all electronics away
and he'll be he'll be a thousand miles
away from you standing right next to you
holding your hand
okay yeah we've done that there you go
it doesn't work
okay people change that you can
you can compress and power somebody
through something
but at the end of the day you're gonna
have to change their heart through
connectivity okay
and so i want you and your whole family
at some point and this is gonna maybe be
a month or two down the road
he's gotta buy back in that you're all
in on his team
okay here's what that's gonna be it's
gonna be weird i want you a couple of
nights a week to go lay in bed with him
in the evening
go lay next to him in that disgusting
bed that's probably smells and it's full
of sand and all kind of stuff
insane oh yeah it's hey it's gross
i did it with my 11 year old son last
night and i'm not the cleanest guy
and it was oh my gosh
okay but i want you to hold his hand and
say uh i'm your mom
and you have to hold my hand he's gonna
go mom it's good nope you're holding my
hand
okay you don't have to look him in the
eye because that's hard for a 17 year
old and that may be hard for you
i want you to lay by him and say you
have to tell me three things about your
day
three things that were crappy and three
things that were awesome and here's what
we're doing
we are rebuilding connection from the
floor up and you're going first
and my gut tells me is that you don't
know how to do this either
and so you're gonna have to practice
along the way and the more you tell them
i think this is weird and vulnerable but
i think
i miss you not i think this is the right
thing to do
to help your adhd no i miss you you're
my son i love you
and you start from there and then at
some point you're gonna
as a family say hey we're gonna develop
the family rules
all the kids around the table everyone's
gonna vote we're all in this
and that's how you get buy-in so that
when he chooses to just sit in his house
like
i mean sit in his room and not
participate in the family
he's opting he is choosing to
let the family system fall down right i
want you and your husband
to go somewhere and talk about what kind
of outside of a bedroom experience are
we creating that our kids want to go
hide from us
are we just coming home and plopping on
the couch and watching tv ourselves
are we just sitting around arguing or we
telling everybody get this clean up this
do this do that all that
or are we having a laughing family do we
go outside and run around the front yard
are we throwing food at each other not
that you have food fights but is it an
environment that kids want to be a part
of where they see their parents as
humans not as robots
well i know mason will say that he stays
in his room because his
siblings are too loud okay
well hey here's the thing a key factor
or a key thing of adhd
is sensitivity and it makes people nuts
and you'll look at them and go
what do you mean sensitive you're
watching anime blowing out the rods and
cones in your eyes and you've got
headphones on 24 7
listening to house music and you're you
know you're going deaf
it just it just depends on certain
people at certain times
i sit in my house and i think it feels
like elephants are running around and i
look around and it's an 11 year old and
a five-year-old and they're just
laughing having fun so i have to
remember the problem is me
and so that's when you tell him i want
you to be a part of this
family if they're being too loud i want
him to learn some skills not
not disconnection and running away he
can learn some skills to say
hey guys let's color instead let's do
something let's
engage that the problem not run away
from it
not power through it right i want you
guys to have hard conversations in the
coming months about
sleep about nutrition about physical
space i want you to clean your room a
lot of kids with adhd especially 17 year
olds their rooms are
nightmarish right oh my gosh we
just took three garbage bags full of
stuff out of his room it was awful
awesome well i'm glad you did that
hopefully it wasn't a fight hopefully
it goes back to that don't forget to
remember right there's
nothing better for an adhd kid to wake
up in a room full of order
and it's clean that's that's that makes
an adhd soul
breathe and the adhd soul forgets to
clean up the room every day
right it's maddening right
and so it's that don't forget to
remember my wife tells me that
when we go out to eat and i'm about to
just unload on some food she'll say hey
don't
just gently don't forget to remember
she's not gonna lecture me don't eat
that because then i'm gonna get all up
mad
why do you always do that she doesn't
because she doesn't pull away she just
gently says hey don't forget to remember
and i know that she's saying don't
forget to remember that you're not going
to sleep tonight if you eat 11 pieces of
pizza
don't forget to remember that if you
have more beers
you're going to snore all night you're
not going to sleep you can feel terrible
tomorrow
don't forget to remember and then i go
oh yeah
i was about to forget how bad tomorrow's
going to be if i don't live into this
now
but listen she's only allowed to do that
because she leans into
not away from she doesn't lecture she
loves
she doesn't try to power through she
tries to connect
all of this with the 17 year old though
starts with you saying i'm sorry
it starts with you saying i've wanted
the best for you and i didn't have the
right tools in my toolkit so we're going
to learn how to do this together
i want to direct you to what i think is
the masterpiece the seminal work on adhd
it's called scattered
by dr gabor mate m-a-t-e and we'll link
to it in the show notes here
um it's the masterpiece and it's a hard
read
it's a hard read my wife wept through a
lot of it right
because you start to take ownership of
the ecosystem that's
in your home and we've had to work
through like me it's not your fault it's
just what we know it's just what we know
and let's work on this together and it's
been a magical transition in my house
okay it's called scattered by gabor mate
parents whose kids are struggling with
adhd number one
go back and look at the ecosystem the
kid developed in
number two look at how you are trying to
get them to do what you want them to do
is it through power is it through
coercion is it through i'm just gonna
medicate you
or is it through connection
and purpose and what do you love what do
you love
right what like what do you love and i'm
gonna draw connections if your kid
loves soccer and obsessed with soccer
just wants to play soccer never wants to
do homework
we're going to draw connections between
soccer man you can do hard things
you're really good at this and look at
that
i want you to apply those same skills in
the classroom right because in this
house we all
value responsibility right
that's a lot thank you so much for the
call um man
thank you so so much for that call sarah
i get so many calls about adhd if you've
got more
more questions on it give me a call um
i want us to begin to approach this
through connection not through power
and coercion thank you so so much for
the call and by the way
i'm not a hippie i'm a
i'm not i just want you to always go
back
and ask yourself this one question is
what i'm doing making my life better
am i actually solving this problem we
just need to do it faster and harder and
louder
often you're not right often you're not
right